today on the Matt Walsh show Joe Biden
has been as the media would say if it
was a Republican credibly accused of
sexual assault
the media and me to movement have shown
zero interest in this story they were
just not interested all their their
their plan is to ignore it but Joe Biden
is unfortunately for him on the record
saying that we should believe women in
these situations we should just believe
them so the question is shouldn't we
hold Joe Biden to his own standard
that's what we'll talk about today also
five headlines including the media
celebrating celebrating over the fact
that the US has supposedly now the most
coronavirus cases of any country in the
world but there's a big problem with
that statistic and we'll discuss that
and today we canceled a police
department in the UK that is essentially
trying to turn Black Mirror into a
real-life thing and it's it's pretty
creepy we'll talk about that coming up
so all that on the way but first a quick
word from liquid IV you know this is I
would say to put it mildly this is not a
good time to let your body get
dehydrated I think you need to stay
healthy and that's just in general
across the board not not just in these
times but in general you know to staying
hydrated making sure that it really
really the goal is you don't want to get
to a point in the day where you're
really thirsty because that means you're
already in the process of being
dehydrated liquid IV
cellular transport technology delivers
an optional ratio of nutrients for more
efficient uptake and probably means
optimal probably optimal ratio either
way enhanced rapid absorption in the
bloodstream gives you a lasting energy
boost and it does that very fast
it powers your mornings fuels long days
at work I you know what I'll do is I'll
start the morning with it and and I
found that it's it's even better you're
getting really well hydrated is even
it's it's much better than coffee
because coffee also dehydrates you
liquid IV is the fastest-growing
wellness brand and you can find them
everywhere this these days find liquid
IVs hydration multiplier and your local
Costco you could find it at Whole Foods
all the places that are still open by
the way you can find them there and
that's an I know I could not personally
recommend it
and it's as I've been you know using the
liquid IV I've been staying more hydrate
and I really feel the difference as well
you get 25% off when you go to liquid IV
calm and use code Walsh at checkout
that's 25% off anything you order on
liquid IVs website just go to liquid IV
liquid IV dot-com
enter code Walsh and save 25% off and
get better hydration better energy
that's liquid IV calm promo code Walsh
don't wait start fueling your adventures
today okay let's get right into this a
woman by the name of Tara Reid alleges
that she was sexually assaulted by Joe
Biden back in 1993 Reid worked for Biden
when he was a senator back in 93 for
about nine months apparently now a
little bit of background she says and
this is entirely consistent with what
we've seen and what we've heard from
other women she says that before we even
get to the assault she says that he was
very handsy very inappropriate in in in
the workplace with the way that he was
he dealt with especially women he would
often grab women grope them and so on
she says that she did report him
officially through the normal chain of
command for sexual harassment not for
the assault but she reported the
harassment back way back when and now so
that's that's that's the background of
sort of the general environment in the
workplace now when we get to the sexual
assault I think for that rather than me
describing it we'll let Tara Reid in her
own words describe it she was on the
Katie halper show a couple days ago
talking about describing her assault I'm
gonna play it for you now a warning it
is a little bit graphic so just a fair
warning ahead of time especially if you
have kids or in the room maybe you want
to listen to this later but here is Tara
Reid talking about the alleged assault
that she suffered at the hands of Joe
Biden he just said hey come here Tara
and then I handed him the thing and he
greeted me he remembered my name and
then it we were alone and it was the
strangest thing
there was no like exchange really he
just had me up against the wall
and I was wearing like a skirt and you
know BEC is a skirt but I wasn't wearing
stockings it was kind of a hot day that
day and I was wearing heels and I
remember my legs had been hurting from
the marble you know of the Capitol like
walking and I remember that kind of
stuff I remember like that and it was
kind of an unusually warm day and I
remember I was wearing a blouse and he
just had me up against the wall and the
wall was cold and I remember he it
happened all at once the gym bag I don't
know what when I handed it to him was
gone and then his hands were on me and
underneath my clothes and yeah and then
he went um he went down my skirt but
then up inside it and he kind of treated
me with those years and um I he was
kissing me at the same time and he was
saying something to me he said several
things and I can't remember everything
he said I remember a couple of things I
remember him saying first if like as he
was doing it do you want to go somewhere
else and then him saying to me when I
pulled away he um got finished doing
what he was doing and I I was pulled
back and he said he said come on man I
heard you liked me now there are no
witnesses to this she did apparently
though tell her brother and and her
friends so she told two people she says
the intercept which is a different media
outlet they spoke with the brother and
the friend and both of those people
confirmed that she reported the assault
to them back when it allegedly happened
be out beyond that there's no evidence
so what should we do about this there
are aspects of it that do make it
credible on its own terms I think we
know that Biden does get handsy with
women we know that we've seen it
ourselves with our own eyes we know that
he's been accused of inappropriate
conduct in the past and from other women
and again we've seen it ourselves
she says she reported harassment back in
1993 she also says she told two people
about the assault the alleged assault
wouldn't happen and they confirm it
now that's pretty significant because
Ford Christine Ford with Kavanagh she
didn't have that she didn't have anyone
come out and say oh yeah you know she
told me about this when it happened back
thirty years ago in fact it was the
opposite she had people come out and say
I knew her I was her best friend and she
never told me a damn thing about this
now does it mean that an accusation is
true just because a woman told her
friend about it back when it supposedly
happened no but it does seem to rule out
the possibility that this was cooked up
in the spur of the moment recently as a
way to get attention or something during
a political campaign or as a way to
destroy a political foe because because
then why why would she have invented it
the story 2627 years ago only to tell
two people and then come forward all
these years later it doesn't seem like
what you would do if you were just
making something up for political
reasons or in order to sue somebody and
get money you know all of the
motivations that I think do sometimes
lead people to inventing false
allegations now again does that mean
that it really happened no it doesn't
mean that necessarily we don't know what
happened there should be a presumption
of innocence at least I believe in a
presumption of innocence you know and
we'll stop there for a minute because we
know that the court of public opinion
doesn't necessarily function that well
we know doesn't function like the court
of law and shouldn't always function
like a court of law
I mean for example I have no problem
sitting here and saying I think that OJ
Simpson is guilty of double murder
I absolutely believe that 100% he was
found not guilty in a court of law so a
court of law has to operate by certain
certain rules certain laws that are
necessary that doesn't mean that we as
individuals can't just use our common
sense and look at a situation and say
yeah I think he did even if he was found
not guilty but when we have a
circumstance like this in accusation
years later decades later where there's
no real evidence at all then what do you
do that I think you do even the court of
public opinion should most of the time
function like a court of law and we say
well look all we can do is you know we I
guess we have to get the benefit of
doubt to the accused in this case
because there's no evidence but the
problem oh for Biden is that someone
once said actually very recently said
and I'll give you a quote this is what
somebody said somebody said for a woman
to come forward in the glaring lights of
focus nationally you've got to start off
with the presumption that at least the
essence of what she's talking about
is real and of course the person who
said that was Joe Biden Biden said that
about the Cavanaugh hearings only what a
year ago in reference to Ford's
allegations against Cavanaugh that's his
standard that's the standard that he
said and he's there's there's plenty of
other stuff in in this vein here he is a
play quick clip for you here he is on
the Today Show talking about the
Cavanaugh allegations and relating it
back to a need a hill as well listen to
what he says here the woman should be
given the benefit of the doubt and not
beaten not be you know abused again by
the system my biggest regret was I
didn't know how I could shut you off you
were senator and you were attacking the
hills character under the Senate rules I
can't gavel you down and say you can't
ask that question although I tried and
so what happened was she got victimized
again during during the process and I
believed her when she came forward
I'm couraged her to come forward we were
in a position where we got the FBI to do
an investigation and I voted against
Clarence Thomas he only got seven votes
he got seven yes and seven noses at I
vote in the committee but I hope that
they understand what courage it takes
for someone to come forward and relive
what they let they believe happened to
them the woman should be given the
benefit of the doubt not be abused again
victimized again I believed her these
are all the things he's saying now we'll
talk more about this in just a second
but before we do I want to tell you
about a new sponsor on the show that I'm
that I am especially very excited about
and that is beard supply okay now if
you're sitting at home and you're trying
to grow the the Quarantine beer doesn't
know a lot of people are yeah well I
what I cannot stress enough is the
importance of beard hygiene you got to
keep everything and I know we could all
let our hygiene slip we can all let our
appearance slip in these times but you
have to have respect for your beard as a
man and so you still should practice
good beard hygiene and and keep
everything in top shape and that's what
you need beer supply for beards can get
dry they can get itchy they can I hate
to say this it sounds heretical but they
can even look bad sometimes they can't
look bad if you don't take care of them
now I'm speaking from experience because
I've had you know I when I first tried
to try to grow a beard it looked I just
it looked like Tom Hanks in castaway it
was not very good beard supply though
helps keep keep your beard healthy itch
free soft it also smelling great and
it's right on your face you want it to
smell good too that's the other part of
beards and more than 10,000 beards agree
beard supply products are the best out
there 10,000 beards can't be wrong
beard cannot be wrong I believe beards
just listen to what some of these beards
are saying Jacob's beard says Chuck
Norris added me to his list of worthy
opponents after I used beard supply so
that's a pretty good that's it that's a
good endorsement there Paul's beard says
this is simply the best beard oil I have
ever tried each beard supplied beard oil
is hand crafted from 100% natural
ingredients with no synthetics no
mass-market essentials nothing like that
this stuff is basically just squeezed
right out of the earth directly onto
your beard which is the way it should be
plus they come in tons of great smells
like the woods or winter which has a
year or the year 1975 also has a smell
so you could join Jacob Paul and
thousands of other bearded guys who are
enjoying softer better smelling better
smelling less itchy beards for short
time beard supplies offering Matt Walsh
o listeners 25% off just go to beard
supply.com use promo code Walsh again
that's beard supply.com beard supply.com
promo code Walsh okay so we just played
for you what Joe Biden has said in
reference to allegations against men by
women accusing them of sexual assault
now according to Joe Biden at least on
the two occasions when there was a
conservative justice he wanted to keep
off the court in those cases we should
give accusers the benefit of doubt we
should presume that what they're saying
is true in essence and not abuse them
again which of course insinuates that
they were abused the first time by
asking too many questions or whatever
else that's Biden's standards his rule
should we apply this standard then to
Joe Biden should we apply the Biden
standard to Biden I say yes we should
it's only out of a it's only I think
it's a matter of respect for him that we
do that he's told us how he wants us to
handle these situations and he wants a
presumption of guilt for the man who was
accused he told us that so I think all
we can do here is respect his wishes
this is what he wants not what I want
it's what he wants isn't that the fair
thing to say well okay Joseph what you
want this is this you told us to handle
these situations this way so that's what
we're gonna do are we gonna disrespect
Joe Biden by giving him the presumption
presumption of innocence when he's been
very clear and very consistent that he
doesn't think that should be applied to
the man why should we so I'll say right
now you know I believe her I believe
this woman I believe Tara Reid believe
all women right I believe her
that's not my philosophy but I think you
know I'm gonna let you have your
philosophy no double standards you get
one standard one standard I think
everybody should get one standard when
it comes to these things that's all you
get you don't get to and if you've said
if you've made it clear that the
standard should be believe all women
then guess what that's what you get if
you like your standard you can keep your
standard how about that um and I think
we have to hold these hypocrites to
their own standards because they're not
gonna do it they don't have that kind of
integrity so what's the other option
we're just gonna allow them to pick up a
different standard depending on the
situation by the way speaking of lacking
integrity and double standards Reid went
to the me2 movement with this story and
they had no interest in it here's what
the Federalist reports reading now from
a federal star article based based on
the intercepts reporting says the time's
up legal defense fund a fund
administered by the National Women's Law
Center declined the chance to defend one
of former Vice President Joe Biden's
sexual harassment accusers citing its
nonprofit status and his presidential
run on Tuesday the intercepts Ryan Grimm
reported that Tara Reid one of several
women to come forward with credible
allegations of harassment against Biden
last spring not just harassment but
assault was turned away from the
preeminent meet to legal institution
when she sought help with her case
time's up argued that the case was too
political considering that Biden was a
candidate for president the article goes
on from there
so the meatsuit movement which has told
us to believe all women all of a sudden
isn't so interested in that anymore are
they
and the mainstream media you understand
the mainstream media has given this
story many mainstream outlets have given
the story zero coverage no coverage at
all haven't even mentioned it now
usually with stuff like this what
they'll do is they'll they'll mention it
so they can say they did but they'll
bury it
so they'll at least give it a mention
most of the time with this so far a lot
of these outlets have said nothing about
it nothing let's just pretend it doesn't
exist so what do we do do we go along
with it
do we let these people dictate which
accusations should be believed without
question and which will be ignored as if
they never were made to begin with no
hell no you know I look at it like this
when you hear about a one of these
Family Values conservative Republicans
it gets caught in a gay affair or
something now this doesn't happen nearly
as often as the left would like us to
believe doesn't happen doesn't happen
nearly as often as Hollywood betray
portrays it
we know that in you know it's like every
other Hollywood script has a closeted
gay Republican in it so doesn't happen
all that often but it does happen it has
happened a few times at least
and now someone like that gets caught in
a situation like that they ends up they
end up getting judged a lot more harshly
and they're gonna suffer a political
consequence far greater than what maybe
another politician would suffer in the
same sort of situation why because
they're having their own standard
applied to them their own rhetoric their
own statements are being tossed back in
their direction and that is fair that
seems fair to me that it would work that
way it seems fair that you know if
you're if you're uh even if you're a
left winger and you see you had you you
and you personally have no problem with
homosexual activity or even marital
Affairs you can still call for harsh
political consequences for a
conservative family values republican
caught up in that kind of situation on
the basis that their own standards
should be applied to them in the name of
justice in the name of fairness in the
name of consistency and I agree with
that well same thing here
same thing here Jesus said live by the
sword die by the sword that wasn't a
prescription Jesus wasn't
saying that people who live by the sword
should die by the sword he was just
saying that that's what happens if you
live by the sword such is life and in
the same way if you live by believe all
women then you die by it at least
politically you die by it fair is fair I
think one other point I want to make
about this before we move on if a man
says believe all women right and that's
what Joe Biden has said now he maybe
hasn't used those words exactly but
that's what he said he said if a woman
makes an accusation we should presume
that at least the essence of what
they're saying is true which means it's
true the essence is so what what that
means is well maybe a few of the details
are wrong because she forgot it's been
so many years but the essence is true so
if you know translated according to
Biden if a woman says she was assaulted
we should believe that she was assaulted
period it's what he said believe all
women right so now a man who takes that
approach and says believe all women
there are two possible ways of
interpreting because obviously we know
as a principle it's nonsense it's insane
it's madness believe all we of course of
course we shouldn't really believe all
women anymore that we should believe all
men women can lie just like men can lie
but a man who says believe all women I
think there are two ways of interpreting
that there are two things that might
lead a man to say that one is that he's
a liar he's a con artist and he's saying
something that in this case is just for
political gain and he's just pretending
to hold this view for political gain
he's a liar a con man a charlatan okay
maybe that's it the other is that he has
made this judgment earnestly because he
really believes that most men are
degenerates and rapists so it's probably
true when they're accused and when
they're accused the accusations are
probably true but on on what could he
base that judgment well it seems it's
likely that he's probably basing it on
himself he knows that about himself and
he's assuming that it's true of others
so this is projection so either way
whatever leads a man to say believe all
women it does in fact mean as a matter
of logic not just fairness but I think
as a matter of logic that when he is
accused we have good reason to
disbelieve the denials that he issues
because by saying believe all women in
the past it means either he's a liar in
which case we can't we can't believe him
in his denials or he's projected his own
behavior on to other men because he
himself is probably a degenerate in
which case we can't trust his denials
either so I think either way a man who
goes around saying that and then is
accused there's actually good logical
reason to think that he probably did it
and even if there isn't as I said one
standard for everybody this nonsense of
pretending to hold a certain viewpoint
and you throw that to the side whenever
it's politically expedient no nope nope
nope nope no this is what you said
that's the way the game is gonna be
played but of course fortunately for Joe
Biden because the media isn't covering
this he doesn't have to even address it
I'm not sure if he's even issued a
denial yet not because he's not gonna
deny it deny it but just because he
doesn't have to nobody's asked him about
it now we're gonna go to headlines here
in just a second
before we do I want to tell you about
another great sponsor on the show rad
power bikes I think especially these
days once again you know it's it's we're
all looking for ways to to kill some
time and have some fun and maybe you
can't go to places where you're indoors
around a lot of people anymore so you're
looking for some things that you can do
outside things that you know fun things
that you can do that are not the normal
things of going in and and being around
other people and that's where rad power
bikes comes in too
between a traditional bike and a moped
but it doesn't require special driver's
license like a moped would you can go up
to 20 miles per hour without pedaling so
you can get out and about without
without getting all sweaty and
everything it's affordable you know this
is a bike start at $1,200 and all of
them are under $1500 so I think that's
something to really emphasize here and
any of the bikes you look at rad power
bikes can be under 50 on the buck 50
hundred bucks other ebikes can be in the
3000 dollar range or more so you don't
have to worry about that here it's great
for commuting you can get out on the
trail you can haul groceries you could
transport your kids on the back weather
whether for practical purposes or just
for fun and to show appreciation for
those that serve us rad power bikes is
offering $100 off all ebike purchases
for active slash ex-military first
responders teachers and students it's a
great thing to do any time especially
now dedicated us-based customer support
seven days a week to answer any
questions or concerns that you might
have I cannot recommend this enough if
you're looking for something just fun to
do we need to have some fun well how
about rad power bikes rad power bikes
offers flexible financing for as low as
0% APR and right now as a limited time
offer you can get a free accessory with
the purchase of a bike that's right get
a free gift up to $100 in value and free
shipping to the lower 48 states to get
this special offer
text the word bike to 64,000 that's bike
to 64,000 text bike to 64,000 all right
let's go to headlines number one the
media is reporting celebrating really
that the u.s. now supposedly has more
coronavirus cases than any other country
in the world leftists on social media
have been ecstatic about this Jim Acosta
especially could hardly hide the
gloating tone in his tweets about it but
notice something see all these headlines
most cases most cases in the world
well they all actually say confirmed
cases or known cases or reported cases
so we have the most of that we don't
have the most cases we have the most
confirmed known reported cases so what
does that tell you well it tells you
essentially nothing about how many cases
we
actually have in comparison to other
countries it tells you nothing about
that all it tells you is that we've done
the most tests which we have what a
coincidence the country that does the
most tests has the most cases
interesting how that works
Acosta also tweeted triumphantly the US
has just passed China a country four
times larger in population in
coronavirus cases yeah but the thing is
Jimbo in order for that to be true it
needs to also be true that China and the
US have at least tested the same number
of people which they haven't and we need
to be able to trust China's
self-reported data which we can't if you
listen to China they haven't had a new
case in days you know they went from
epidemic to now they have just it's it's
all it's gone it's been cured they
discover the cure it's a miracle do you
believe that does anyone really believe
that no but the media is pretending to
believe and is in fact disseminating
Chinese propaganda in order to get Trump
it is traitorous really number two and
this is becoming a daily occurrence a
rather delightful daily occurrence dr.
Burks during a White House press
briefing
once again smack down the press for
their coronavirus sensationalism and
this woman is fantastic I I can't get
enough of it I think it's great watch
the latest here we were reassured and
meeting with our colleagues in New York
that there are still ICU beds remaining
and they're still significant over a
thousand or 2,000 ventilators that have
not been utilized yet please for the
reassurance of people around the world
to wake up this morning and look at
people talking about creating DNR
situations do not resuscitate situations
for patients there is no situation in
the United States right now that
warrants that kind of discussion you can
be thinking about it in a hospital
certainly many hospitals talked about
this on a daily basis but to say that to
the American people to make the
implication that when they need a
hospital bed it's not going to be there
or when they need that ventilator it's
not going to be there
we don't have an evidence of that right
now and it's our job collectively to
assure the American people that it's our
collective job to make sure that doesn't
happen there's no model right now I mean
no reality on the ground where we can
see that 60 to 70 percent of Americans
are going to get infected
in the next 8 to 12 weeks I just want to
be clear about that
okay I want you to keep that in mind as
we go to number three this headline in
Yahoo and in many other outlets as well
had it yesterday blaring all over the
place headline is us virus deaths may
top 80,000 despite confinement 80,000
despite the fact that everyone's locked
down the article continues covered 19
could lead to more than 80,000 deaths in
the US and overwhelm hospital capacity
nationally as soon as early April
as soon as early April which is in like
what three days new research showed on
Thursday the US death toll for the
pandemic has already soared past a
thousand with 68,000 confirmed
infections forecasters at the Institute
for Health metrics and evaluation at the
University of Washington School of
Medicine analyzed the latest kovat 19
data at a local national international
level these include hospitalization and
mortality rates as well as patient data
in a date in terms of age gender and
pre-existing health conditions
specifically they looked at the time lag
between the first fatal cases and public
interventions such as shuttering schools
and businesses and they put all this
together and they decided that 80,000
people are going to die there are 1,300
deaths right now or there abouts here in
the US this study says it's going to
shoot up to 80,000 in a few days really
now there are a lot of studies and a lot
of models at this point a lot of
projections a lot of predictions by
various different experts and they all
say drastically different things the
question is why is the media blaring
this one all over the place as opposed
to any of the others well we know the
answer to that of course it's because
it's the scariest
it's significantly less scary than what
they were predicting two weeks ago when
they said that you know two or three
million or four million people are gonna
die now its 80,000 but they're always
gonna go with the scariest and put that
in the headlines that's how this works
that's what we've learned if we didn't
know it already
finally some crucially important
reporting from CNN well this is number
four I guess I don't have five I can't
count okay we'll end on four five
headlines is for today so CNN published
a report or broadcast report actually
that is really important I think it's
life-saving and I think we all will
learn a lot from this all right I'm
going to show you how to wash your hands
most people know how to do this but
always worth remembering just gonna wet
my hands here get plenty of soap and
just start rubbing your hands and make
sure you really interlace your fingers
like this and then also turn your hands
over don't forget the backs of your
hands people often forget that both
sides get it really well and then I'll
actually get underneath the fingertips
here and even the nails a little bit to
make sure you clean underneath there and
then you got to get the thumbs thumbs
are really important sing the Happy
Birthday song twice to yourself and that
usually will do it and then I just sort
of get the soap off my hands here and
there and then here's the key before you
turn the water off dry your hands and
use the same paper towel turn off the
water you don't contaminate yourself oh
so that's how you do it see I had no
idea that's I I had thought I've been
doing it wrong this whole time I thought
that the way you wash your hands do
stand on your you stand on your head and
yodel that's the hand washing maneuver I
had been using I didn't realize that
apparently you're supposed to use what
was it what he said says it was a stomp
SAP what was that thing so so Bose use
soap and you put your hands under uh
what was it I got to go back and look at
again I didn't take notes wah wah
there's stuff water soap and water is
what you use that's incredible thank you
so much you know see I'm glad that CNN
is doing reports like this telling us
how to wash our hands rather than doing
something like I don't know
investigating and reporting the sexual
assault allegations against the
Democratic frontrunner for the
nomination for president uh you know I
know II don't wanna do that that's
that's not newsworthy instead let's
bring a doctor in here to show us how to
wash our hands not patronizing at all
either you know in the least so thank
you so much for that CNN now we're gonna
go on to your daily cancellation and it
is quite a doozy this time but before we
do if you haven't had a chance to check
out yet the all-access live show then I
would really recommend doing that and in
fact eight o'clock tonight Eastern Time
5 p.m. Pacific you can watch again the
think about the all exits live it's very
relaxed programming more of a casual
kind of vibe a conversation so usually
we put I mean you look at this set here
millions and millions of dollars dumped
into making this set look as magnificent
as it does but that's the all-access
live isn't about that it's just about
the casual at the end of a long day in
the middle of a very long what feels
like an eternity
over the last few weeks it's a good time
to just kind of sit there and and have a
conversation the show is originally
intended for all access members but it's
during this national emergency we've
expanded it extended it to all of our
members and in doing so we've
accelerated the launch as well so please
join us tonight 8:00 p.m. Eastern 5:00
p.m. Pacific for another all-access show
it's a lot of fun I think you'll enjoy
it now for your daily cancellation today
we're canceling the Derbyshire police
police department in the UK obviously
what they've been doing is they've been
using drones to enforce their stay at
home order and anyone so that means
anyone who's caught outside walking
around is recorded by the drone and then
they're shamed on social media for being
outside already we've got enough to
cancel them wait we don't have to go any
further already we know cancelled right
but you have to actually watch you have
to see this video to appreciate just how
ridiculous this is
let me I'll play it for you and I'll
follow along as we watch this video that
the Derbyshire police at
Derby's police on twitter they post this
to Twitter and let's check out the video
so it said this is curb our edge it says
now you see out there in the middle of
in the middle of nowhere these vehicles
should not be here
okay they're out in the middle of
nowhere in a field in a park and now we
see walking your dog in the Peak
District not essential not essential a
human's life forms you are participating
in not essential activity go back to
your home's going for a walk miles from
home not essential your activity has
been judged not essential return to your
domicile humans going out of your way
for an Instagram snap not essential not
essential activity return to your
domiciles and now this one driving to a
beauty spot for a stroll not essential
can't do that either you're gonna get
people sick I don't know how you're
gonna get people sick but you will
heading to heading to the peaks to watch
the sunset not essential let's pause it
here for just a minute they're going to
the peaks to watch the Sun [ __ ] you
can't watch a sunset during a pandemic
you just can't do it why can't you do it
I have no idea it's dangerous
during a pandemic to watch a sunset why
is it dangerous don't know but the drone
said it is so you can't watch a sunset
let's see the rest of this year the
government advice is clear you should
only travel if it is essential traveling
tour
of the Peak District for your exercise
is not essential we are all in this
together and then the end with the
please help us please help us stay home
save lives well I gotta end it with the
little positive the Orwellian positivity
there then we're all in this together
stay home and save lives
let me ask you people that are walking
by themselves down a country road in a
field not another human within sight
right literally not another human within
sight what how are they putting lives in
jeopardy how are they at risk of
infecting anybody else there's nobody
around them they're in the wilderness
are they at risk of getting infected now
again if this was the zombie apocalypse
and I know the media really wishes it
was a zombie apocalypse it seems like
some law enforcement agencies kind of
wish it was a zombie apocalypse I sort
of wish it was a zombie apocalypse too
because frankly this apocalypse has been
not as active as I thought you know the
apocalypse has it has involved a lot
more sitting around than I imagined that
it would so look we would all prefer
zombies but there are no zombies and so
if you're walking down the countryside
there really isn't any danger of
something jumping out from behind a tree
or from buying a bush and infecting you
that's not how viruses are transmitted
my question to the Derbyshire police how
do you think what is your theory of
transmission for this disease how do you
think it's transmitted do you think that
somebody's sitting in their homes 50
miles away who's infected with the with
the corona virus do you think the virus
is going to jump out of their mouths and
like crawl speedily across the carpet
open the door go outside maybe hop on a
hop on a bus go to a bus station get out
travel across the field 14 miles and
then hide behind a curb a curve and as
soon as a person comes walking around
there jump out right
attack their face crawl into their nose
is that how you think it works now if
the government has information
indicating that the guy that the virus
does spread that way then please let us
know because if that's the case I will
definitely be staying inside my house
and not leaving for any reason
whatsoever but I'm pretty sure that this
virus is spread mainly by like if
somebody you know if you touch something
that someone left their bodily fluids on
and then you put your hands in your
mouth spread that way if they coughed
like right in your face spread that way
not essential yeah you're right these
are not essential activities but you
know what this is what makes us human
the fact that we participate in
non-essential activities that's what
makes us human yeah a squirrel or a deer
or porcupine isn't going to stop to
watch a sunset humans do it's what makes
us human and so you can't tell us that
during a pandemic we have to cease
participating in all human activity and
pretend to be bears hibernating under
under in a cave somewhere there's
there's just no reason whatsoever why
people can't go out for a walk on the
countryside
there's just no reason there's no reason
for that this is a power trip by the
government that's what it is and the
problem is if we start to see that the
government is having a power trip not
just the Derbyshire police but we talked
yesterday about Chicago the Chicago
mayor is saying if you want to go
outside your house and go out briefly go
back in being outs outside is not for
five K's she I think that was her exact
phrasing she's now telling us what the
outside is for if you're in Chicago the
mayor has decided what outside exists
for the entire outside she'll tell you
what it's for okay this is her outside
not yours these are the things you're
allowed to do outside anything less than
that get back inside you peasant but but
when we start to see these these naked
power trips not literally naked
hopefully but when we start to see these
power trips then we started thinking
okay well they're obviously power
tripping over here with this what else
of this is a power trip let's go to
emails you can become a daily wire
member and send emails to the mailbag
from Ben that says hello Matt since on
quarantine I thought it'd be a good idea
to begin to grow some facial hair so far
I've gone a week without shaving I have
a few questions will the constant
annoying itching disappear as my facial
hair grows longer or should I be using a
beard product of sorts to reduce this
sensation how long should I wait until I
cut my losses and accept that my facial
hair won't look very good how will I
know if I should go with the style of
full facial hair or just a partial any
other beginner tips will be appreciated
too thank you for your time and I hope
you and the family are staying healthy
Ben first of all stop whining about the
itching you are unworthy of your beard
when you're sitting there whining and
bitching about the itching it should be
forcibly removed from your face you
should be grateful that you're growing a
beard you should be ecstatic that you
are joining now the ranks of bearded men
that is you're joining the ranks of real
men you are now a man or becoming one
for the first time in your life
gratitude and humility are the two
attitudes that you should be bringing to
this endeavor not one of complaint and
entitlement that is for the baby safe
the baby-faced freaks okay and that is
the group that you are leaving and
rightfully so don't be like them second
yes you should be using product you can
get beard oil beard balm beard wax beard
we just talked about beard supply ok
beard supply great great place to look I
tend to use many products from my beard
and not right now because I have a very
short beard of the beard of a child at
the moment it's much to my shame but
when I have a real beard by my beard
prepping routine usually takes about 7
to 8 hours so the days basically over by
the time
I'm preparing my beard and and really
it's kind of destroyed my life because
all I ever do is prepare my beard and
it's become a whole thing but don't
focus on that the main thing is you want
to make sure your beard is properly
prepped when should you cut your losses
and accept that your facial hair won't
look good well I just want to be clear
about this if your beard doesn't look
good it's not your beards fault it is
your fault it is your faces fault okay
so don't blame it on the beard don't
take it out on the beard as a man the
primary responsibility of your face is
to serve as a platform for your beard so
if you're looking at your beard and
thinking this looks weird no it's your
face that's weird okay your face is
failing in its responsibilities your
face is a disgrace so that's all I would
say about that if you think of my beard
looks weird just consider the
possibility that you are a hideous
person and that's why take it from me
okay so I know that about myself it's
not my anytime I have a problem with the
beard it's not the beers on this part
down here it's all up here
okay this is all a mess and out of place
this is the good part of my thing this
is the only good part of my face this up
here is you know makes me want to become
a Muslim woman like wear like a burka or
something to face it to hide it but but
that's that's the point is that is not
don't take it out on your beard that's
all I'm trying to tell you okay let's go
to Adam says Matt you're wrong about the
stimulus checks you say we might as well
burn the money because it's not going to
pay everyone's bills that's obviously
stupid and it sounds like you're just
you just like to complain how about be
happy that they're trying to do
something at least it may not be great
but it's something why not try some
gratitude for a change your negativity
is exhausting right okay Adam a few
problems here first of all my point
about the stimulus checks is that we're
sending checks to a lot of people who
don't need it there gonna be a lot of
people who still have an income and
we're sending them however many millions
or billions of dollars are being spent
on people like this have it income
they're working from home or you know
maybe they work at a place that hasn't
closed
and they're they're still in the exact
same spot they were now that they were
that they were before all this started
what are we setting them money for I
don't think we could just say yeah you
know yeah a couple billion bucks we
wasted on them sad no big deal
what's a few billion between friends no
what are we sending their money for and
then there are many people who don't
have an income and won't get a check
because they made too much money two
years ago too much according to the
government's arbitrary cutoff line and
then there are a lot of other people who
do need it and will get it and but how
many of them will actually be able to
live on 1200 bucks for the duration of
the lockdown
a few maybe what percentage the rest are
still gonna have to find some other
income stream or they're gonna be out on
the street not able to afford food it's
like either way right the stimulus money
in and of itself for those people
doesn't do a whole lot if you have no
income stream right now and because the
government's taken it from you and your
mortgage is $2,000 you can't just send
in 1200 most landlords of yo if you owe
fifty hundred bucks and rent and you
with most landlords anyway you can't
just give him twelve hundred and say
let's just call twelve we'll call it
even
what do you say what do you say they're
gonna say no I need the full amount and
so you know having part of your rent
effectively ends up it's not much better
than having none now look if it were
free if we had a magical money tree and
there were no cost to this then sure I'd
say who cares whatever you know for 1200
odds better than nothing just said it
but it's not free this cost trillions of
dollars gonna be six trillion dollars
all in six trillion debt that will be on
the shoulders of our children to deal
with so call me crazy Adam but I'd
prefer if it actually made a positive
impact a substantial noticeable positive
impact an impact that is worth the
enormous astronomical inconceivable cost
attached to it and I haven't even gotten
into all the left-wing pork
I haven't gotten into you know how the
bill in some ways incentivizes companies
to layoff employees and there are so
many problems with the spell I haven't
even gotten into that now as to this
idea that I should be positive and
cheerful and happy at least they did
something I find that idea nauseating
frankly would you say they oh they did
something who are they are we talking
about children I mean yeah there are
emotional or mental children that we
have in Congress but actual children no
are these are these my kids who drew me
a picture and I should be happy with it
even if it kind of sucks I should say ah
wolf howl it's beautiful thank you so
much it's so great what a great picture
pat him on the head no these are
lawmakers these are people in power
these are people who hold the purse
strings that have the money your money
my money okay we shouldn't smile and nod
and say oh at least you tried at least
you tried you did something thank you so
much thank you yeah this bill is an
absolute garbage he because six trillion
dollars is putting us even deeper in
debt debt that's gonna be on our
children but thank but thank you so much
thank you for trying
you try thank you so much lawmakers
bullcrap you think they have that
attitude towards you when the government
comes around come tax day and says you
owe X amount you know can you just send
the IRS like a couple of paper clips and
the and a pack of fruit snacks and say
hey you know this is this is what I
tried I'm trying I tried to give you
something it's something better than
nothing I gave you something no they're
gonna say no no no not something this is
how much you owe
give us that full amount okay or you can
work out a payment plan but give us the
full amount or you're going to jail how
about that bud that's what the
government says to you the government
makes demands of you and says do this
exactly this or jail and so you want to
turn around and respond to them by
saying well you know you don't really
have to even do anything just try just
give just giving it just give a a plus
effort and that's all we need you had
fun didn't you
as long as you have some fun while you
do it what a disgusting gross attitude
it makes me sick to my stomach I might
vomit right here when I hear this kind
of attitude you're not alone Adam
there's so many Americans that operate
this way I think you've all been
unconscious your whole lives that you
would that you that you think there are
a lot of people with this bill who say
that's terrible
it's terrible but it's something they
did something what how could you
if you've been paying even a moderate
amount of attention how could you still
think that the government doing
something is always better than it doing
nothing at all
if the some if it's a choice between
doing something counterproductive and
destructive and that cost six trillion
dollars on top of it and or doing
nothing if those are the two choices
nothing or counterproductive destructive
cost six trillion dollars
nothing is definitely so much better in
that case this attitude of as long as
they're doing something no no again have
you
paying attention at all your whole life
what so what do you think what I'm
saying about the people in power
lawmakers I I don't want them to do
something okay I want them to do the
right thing that's what I pay them for I
want them to do their job a good job
imagine that perish the thought
you want me to lower the bar except less
that's what you think the problem is you
think the problem is we hold our
lawmakers to too high a standard you
want to have a cheerful optimism while
they just march us right off a cliff
whistling Dixie the whole way you know
goes because you're you're at least
you're let's be positive let's keep it
upbeat attitude let's have an upbeat
attitude while the government takes us
right off a cliff don't be a negative
Nancy about it yeah I am kind of
negative I am kind of negative about our
collection of narcissists and cowards
and con men that we have in Washington
but yeah you're right you're right I
guess I should just I guess I should
just learn to you know to like it learn
to like it
good point Adam thanks so much for the
email really really great stuff very
insightful too and I thank you for that
thanks everybody for watching I hope you
have a great weekend hope you also maybe
could take a break from watching the
news and being online and everything and
and I think for all of our mental health
I'm gonna try the same and it might it
might help us in a lot of ways during
this time have a great weekend Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer austin stevens editor
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle well
tune in to the Ben Shapiro show we will
get a whole lot of that and much more
see you there